et voilà Jean merci c'est pas la vraie
on nous dit
ça s'est bien passé le grand cabaret
avec Patrick Sébastien très bien vous
êtes partis avant la chanson de la fin
ah ça décoiffe quand même
alors
Gina Lollobrigida vous savez que vous
êtes la première femme dont j'ai été
amoureux vraiment vraiment je peux vous
le dire ce soir j'étais fou d'amour pour
vous tellement amoureuse des mois
à l'époque tu sais qu'à l'époque à
l'époque rien que de dire rien que de
dire le nom oui oui on sait Gina Lolo
Brigida quand on disait Lolo c'est déjà
un péché c'est déjà un péché donc on
répéter votre nom comme ça à l'école
alors vous avez été consacré d'ailleurs
j'étais pas le seul être amoureux de
vous la plus belle femme du monde et
vous avez été mon fantasme et le
fantasme million d'hommes Gina pendant
pendant des années ça vous le savez bien
où là je sais pas ce qu'il y a eu
alors au cinéma la carrière est énorme
au cinéma vous avez été Adeline de
Fanfan Latulippe Esmeralda de Notre-Dame
de Paris la reine de Saba Pauline
Borghèse avant de vous retirer au milieu
des années 70 de la vie
cinématographique pour vous lancer dans
la photographie et dans la sculpture oui
c'est-à-dire que avant le cinéma ma vie
était la direction des
la peinture la sculpture et par hasard
le destin a décidé que je devais aller
de l'autre côté le côté du cinéma alors
vous êtes lancé dans la photographie
ensuite dans la sculpture et vous
exposez aujourd'hui au Musée de la
Monnaie à Paris du 10 octobre au 4
janvier des sculptures que vous avez
réalisées en regard à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il y a une monumentale Esmeralda
de bronze qui fait 5 mètres de haut et
48 quinteaux
elle pèse cette question une Esmeralda
qui a votre visage donc chaque fois
c'est fait tu as jamais eu qu'une
Esmeralda c'est bon deux années de
travail pour faire ça c'est sérieux bien
sûr
alors immortaliser dans le bronze et le
marbre il y a d'autres personnages de
vos films et la reine de Saba il y a
Pauline Borghèse et puis il y a des
femmes que vous admirez comme Marilyn
Monroe par exemple c'était une copine
que j'ai eu la le plaisir d'être avec
elle
c'était une femme très sensible très
vulnérable
et elle a payé très cher d'être
dans le public j'étais très près d'elle
elle a jamais eu de chance avec les
hommes Marilyn
monroeuner beaucoup de fois usé il y
avait le sexe à pile d'elle que tout le
monde connaît et il y avait cette
fragilité dans son visage et le
téléphone
près du lit que se rappelle de la fin
qu'elle a fait
vous devriez faire des réponses plus
longues les gens trouvent ça trop
ramassé tais-toi
alors
je vois dans le carré VIP je vois notre
ami de Jack Lang oh là là tout seul
comme une merde
bonjour les amis ça va ça va très bien
vous connaissez Jean je la connais un
peu
il a épinglé absolument lui faire du mal
est-ce que c'est vrai
décoration française
je ne l'oublierai jamais parce que j'ai
jamais vu une fête avec
1000 caméras photographe
mais Jack vous avez épinglé une médaille
et il vous a pincé le sein c'est ça non
c'est pas faux et puis j'étais ému
qui sera président il sera reconnaître
les amis qu'il avait ce qu'ils ont
pleuré
lui notre affection fais-lui un gros
poutou
Laurent tout à l'heure fais un bisou
Laurent poupée d'abord bisous
[Applaudissements]
à pas de cinéma Pas de pantalon pas de
garçons sinon c'était le bâton
l'éducation c'était très dure mais je
dois dire franchement je ne le regrette
pas je ne regrette pas parce que quand
même une éducation très dure ça donne du
caractère et une éducation trop faible
c'est pas bon un autre truc qui n'est
pas bon ici c'est le buffet alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe Laurent tout le
monde ici respecte l'abbé Pierre mais de
là à le prendre comme traiteur on dit
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est Jean-Jacques legoard bien en 1944
Gina quand la guerre éclate en Italie
quand les Alliés remontent l'Italie donc
votre maison est détruite par les
bombardements et et à ce moment-là votre
famille est obligé de quitter la région
vous habitez pour aller à Rome et alors
c'est la fin de l'opulence là vous vivez
à six dans une pièce c'est une période
très difficile de votre vie Gina vos
sœurs sont obligés d'être ouvreuses dans
des dans des cinémas et vous vous
dessinez des portraits de Ji dans la rue
oui aussi et disons tout la famille m'a
aidé parce que moi j'étais l'artiste de
la famille et ils se sont sacrifiés et
on m'a aidé pour que je puisse je
pouvais enfin étudier la peinture alors
pour payer justement vos études
artistiques vos parents acceptent que
vous fassiez de la figuration que vous
preniez des leçons de chant et là vous
vous mettez à faire ce qui est très à la
mode à l'époque en Italie des romans
photos et puis ensuite vous passez du
roman photo ah oui c'est beau le jaune
bilan petite touche hein
un peu comment il va Jack Lang alors il
s'emmerde grave il est tout seul ce type
était très entouré encore dans les
années 50 et maintenant il est seul il
faut absolument qu'ils viennent parce
qu'il s'ennuient alors ensuite vous
passez Jean du roman photo au cinéma
grâce à Silvana Mangano la fameuse
vedette de ryamer alors ensuite vous
êtes Dina vous êtes Miss Italie toi
troisième Miss Italie troisième derrière
Lucia bosse et Diana Maria canal j'avais
quand même des super gonzés à l'époque
en Italie quand tu vois les trois
premières là oui il a pris quelques
films en Italie donc vous allez à
Hollywood appelé par le milliardaire
alors pour nos amis qui ne connaissent
pas wardiaux qu'il faut savoir que il
était très intéressé par les formes
c'est-à-dire qu'il dessinait des avions
et des soutiens-gorges qui est très très
c'est vrai il était très intéressé par
les formes aérodynamiques il vous a fait
venir à Hollywood au hardi Woods et tout
de suite vous avez vous avez compris
tout de suite qui voulait coucher avec
vous on peut le dire il voulait mais
marier mais j'étais déjà marié
j'étais un ange et vous l'avez pas fait
quand même oui j'ai une petite aventure
très intéressant je sais
c'est pas pour le public maintenant
d'accord alors donc vous vous résistez
dites-vous avoir Dieu que je vous
repartez en Italie et là effectivement
il vous envoie ses avocats wardiaux il
vous met des essayez de me faire de mes
frères retourner à Hollywood voilà et
vous avez dû attendre
donc voilà donc ça passe pas bien avec
Wario il faut bien le reconnaître en 52
vous faites Fanfan la Tulipe de
Christian Jacques avec Gérard Philipe
pris de la mise en scène à Cannes énorme
6 millions 7 de téléspectateurs
c'était vraiment le début de ma carrière
internationale je dois aller français
mon succès ça c'est la vérité vous
pensez quoi du remake de Fanfan la
Tulipe avec Vincent Perez et Pénélope
Cruz
c'est une autre chose on peut pas
toucher des bijoux comme Papa la tulipe
spécialement parce que il n'y a pas
chaque jour
et Gérard Philippe non il y a un girafe
ça vous a déçu alors c'est beau c'est de
l'art
ça va prendre forme
[Applaudissements]
gar pour Houston ensuite
Esmeralda la reine de Saba et là vous
êtes une star mais je crois que les gens
se rendent pas compte ce que vous étiez
à l'époque moi je m'en souviens vous
avez rencontré la reine Elizabeth je
vous ai rencontré le président
Eisenhower vous étiez vraiment la reine
du monde quoi
les chefs d'État gynés collection
c'était quand même intéressant mais
j'étais très très intimité par le
premier
alors ensuite c'est très bizarre Gina
parce que vous faites tout un tas de
films qui n'ajoutent rien à votre
filmographie pourquoi vous avez fait des
films moins bien après
parce qu'il n'y avait pas vraiment un
choix et quand je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait vraiment
mieux de ce que j'avais fait je me suis
dit ah c'est le moment où je quitte et
je fais ce que vraiment j'ai dans le
coeur alors disons j'ai travaillé je ne
montrais ni à la presse il n'y a
personne il n'y a rien et cette année je
me suis senti prêt
pour le montrer seulement j'ai exagéré
parce que j'ai accepté trois expositions
à Moscou 38 sculptures après Venise et
Paris mon Dieu ne me touchez pas
alors
bien sûr
ne me l'a pas donné tout ce que j'ai je
vais l'acheter avec mon travail voilà
alors et Laurent vous avez perdu une
boucle d'oreille à l'hôtel à l'hôtel
vous avez perdu une boucle d'oreille
ça c'est l'autre c'est fort j'espère de
le récupérer ça c'est des rubis Sofia
vous êtes pas satisfaite de votre
carrière d'actrice mais vous n'êtes pas
satisfaite non plus de votre vie
amoureuse non non pas du tout pas le bon
Dieu m'a donné du talent
elle m'a dit de l'autre côté la vie
privée
comme moi le premier d'ailleurs un
amoureux de vous mais jamais le grand
amour non pas une seule fois parce que
non parce que les hommes ils sont très
jaloux et quand il y a une femme
belle populaire on a peur d'être
parce que
une femme c'est toujours une femme c'est
pas
spécialement nous Européens on veut pas
dominer non non vous êtes vous êtes en
amour vous êtes soumise et après j'ai
fait semblant d'être dominé
malgré tout vous avez été marié mais bon
voilà vous êtes marié en 49 avec
millekos gothique était un médecin
d'origine yougoslave et votre mère vous
a dit si tu veux te marier autant que ça
soit un médecin ou un avocat parce que
comme ça au moins tu manqueras jamais de
jamais de rien je l'ai eu basta
maintenant j'ai besoin d'un avocat je
n'ai 30000 et vraiment c'est pas c'est
pas
c'est un grand catastrophe non en fait
ce qui est terrible c'est que ce milleko
qui était médecin
il a quitté la médecine pour devenir
votre manager non
oui après il jouait au tennis
en fait
j'ai fait quand même un fils non hein
finalement
15 années avec lui sont aimés c'est bien
alors vous êtes séparés donc en 66 et
divorcé en 71 seulement parce que tu
sais qu'en disant
elle est formidable
mais il faut il faut être dur dans la
vie parce que
la carrière oh non je sais mais ça va
une telle
méchanceté que vous ne pouvez pas savoir
vous inquiétez pas il faut vraiment se
défendre parce que elle vit avec l'homme
le plus détesté des Français il a plus
de bijoux que toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
formidable il a voulu me tuer une fois
pour vous dire il est très très méchant
alors bon on a vu Milko le médecin qui
est devenu votre manager mais il y a eu
d'autres liaisons
dans votre vie il y a eu Sinatra Frank
Sinatra il était très proche
sans plus écoutez moi tout ce que j'ai
voulu dans la vie je l'ai eu briner
parce que
c'est arrivé que on faisait des scènes
d'amour en fait s'embrasser et quand
même il y avait dans le contact il y
avait quelque chose de
là j'arrive au meilleur non alors Dina
dianaçant parce que c'était un barrasant
parce que
quand on s'embrasser le directeur disait
stop mais moi je n'écoutais pas lui non
plus
c'était embarrassant alors là vous
pourrez pas dire le contraire parce que
lui il a été assez mal élevé pour le
dire non pas ici la publier les lettres
c'est le professeur barnaert alors ça
c'est un sujet qui il faut tourner la
page tout de suite écoutez on tourne la
page
il a brisé des cœurs aussi il a pas fait
que les réparer
fidèle Castro
il est pas trop volant
pour une interview up and down
[Musique]
Tina quel a été pour vous le plus bel
âge de votre vie
maintenant
quand on commence à voir disons la
liberté complète de faire vraiment
c'est que on a dans le cœur
il n'y a rien d'autre qui sait plus
important de ça quel a été pour vous le
pire âge peut-être la guerre mais j'ai
appris beaucoup parce que quand on peut
supérer la guerre on est forte et ça ça
aide dans la vie ce que vous préférez
dans le cinéma le cinéma que j'ai vécu
le cinéma où il y a les sentiments où on
peut rêver ce que vous détestez dans le
cinéma
là disons la pornographie
au cinéma non et qu'est-ce que vous
n'avez pas dans le cinéma pornographique
trop de gros plan pas
rêver
il ne faut pas
aller tellement loin que on enlève
complètement
l'imagination et les plaisirs au public
le film de vous que vous préférez alors
je préfère un film que j'ai fait avec
Belmondo où j'étais laide et quand même
j'ai réussi à donner à faire une belle
interprétation la mère à boire je crois
que c'était le film de vous que vous
haïssez tu me rappelles même pas
votre plus belle histoire d'amour alors
c'est quoi
celle que j'ai maintenant avec mon petit
neveu avec votre petit neveu
quand je travaille et il a fait semblant
enfin c'est le fils de Milko junior
quel est votre plus minable histoire
d'amour
ça il faut les oublier il faut pas en
parler la dernière question ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe quand il y a le
sexe et l'amour parce que le sexe ça
peut satisfaire quand on est jeune mais
après on veut que quand même quelque
chose de plus de plus concret ce qui
vous dégoûte le plus dans le sexe
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez quoi de la situation dans
l'Italie de Berlusconi quand Berlusconi
dit Mussolini n'a tué personne il
envoyait les opposants politiques en
vacances
je veux pas commenter tout ce que c'est
disons politiques la seule chose que je
peux dire
que pendant la guerre les Juifs on était
tués
et tout le monde le sait et c'était une
chose que on l'oubliera jamais
spécialement pour les Juifs s'en
souvient pas moi je suis très loin de la
politique c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé italien
avec moi et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu